Reggie Miller Hall of Famer Reggie
continues calling the Western Conference
Finals that'll be with Marv Albert on
tan teak so Game three is Sunday at 8:00
Eastern in Oklahoma City reg doing just
now yeah there is now baby one one okay
do you have it do you feel differently
about this let's say before the series
and then after Game one did your opinion
change about this series no what I've
been surprised about because I didn't
get a chance to see OKC really all
playoffs and I called them during the
regular season and what I'm seeing now
is two different teams more guys are
involved their defense is much better
but at the end of the day I still had
Golden State win in this series in six
you don't win 73 games without being
able to go into someone else's building
and win a game or two it'll definitely
be obviously difficult because of the
way the Thunder is playing but if you
think about it Golden State has not had
a real wire-to-wire signature playoff
game yet because of the injuries to
curry early obviously he's had moments
but curry himself has not put together
48 minutes of the games we've seen first
quarter in third quarter the 15 to 2 run
by curry but he has not had a game we
saw that in Portland it was the fourth
quarter and overtime but not a game full
of curry
if curry did the look to Ibaka back in
the 80s or 90s I loved it I mean it's
entertaining and it's Flair in its style
now now in baseball he okay there he did
hit well let's talk about this because
back in the 80s and 90s you had guys
they were called enforcers the mo Lucas
buck Williams my Davis boys Charles
Oakley
well that's extinct now you can't have a
love tap you can't send the message Bill
Laimbeer Rick Mahorn
if that look would have happened in the
80s or 90s the next time curry would
have drove into the lane he would've
been
Donna's behind and there was not been a
review you gotta you gotta send a
message
you can't send messages there's no more
enforcer you're a four sir your power
forward now is draymond Green yeah I can
handle the basketball shoot threes he's
tough don't get me wrong but the
enforcer role of in the back of your
mind if I Drive in here so someone's
gonna have bad intentions on my body the
that position is no longer in the NBA
Rex Chapman was talking about that this
week on the show and he said Michael
would go to the hoop and you would never
let Jordan dunk on you yeah you had to
hit him right and he knew that if he
went to the hoop he was going yeah
because that's that was his game yes and
in today's game with review with
suspensions with fines in the back of
players minds it's not really worth it
they've taken that all the physicality
they've taken out the hand checking the
armbar the physical play it's gone
explain to me the so-called transparency
with telling us when they've made
mistakes in the final two minutes I like
it because it's not good for the refs no
I don't know how it's good for the game
and the only thing I'd want to know is
are the same officials making these
mistakes or is there a tabulation is
there a sheet that says these guys
aren't among the best referees is there
like what does the price anybody's
payment or the league office is tracking
which officials are making these calls
but let us you know on that as well all
you're gonna have transparency say this
particular ref has done this yes X
amount of time yes no III think they're
doing these officials a disservice by
coming out with that two-minute report
because what about the other four six
there's missed calls during that as well
and as a player as a coach as a fan
don't tell me what I already know don't
tell me when Ginobili gets a four on
Trevor to the chest something didn't
happen when the official is looking
right at him count him how can Marc
Davis the official missed that call the
excuse was he was counting off and
looking at his feet well if he's looking
at his feet he should have seen that
Ginobili cross the line so there's the
first violation why didn't you call that
or what
rook travelling West were travelling or
the non-call that they didn't call on
Kawhi Leonard when he wrapped up Russell
Westbrook and gained three or four I
believe and they went on for the n1
which really sealed the deal so it's one
play I don't want to harp on the
officials because they do do a great job
but I don't like the transparency I
really don't is it the toughest sport to
officiate it is just for the simple fact
you could give a star player one or two
fouls and that can change the outcome or
the look of how you want to approach a
game so official is having one of those
tough days and he gives a Michael Jordan
two quick fouls in the first quarter
well that's gonna affect how the Bulls
play the rest of the way it's LeBron
being officiated differently in what way
because he's not getting to the
free-throw line
well the fouls and and I liken it to
Shaquille O'Neal we can we just haven't
seen player like LeBron is different so
if I'm gonna foul him I have to really
foul him or he'll just continue and and
so you wrap him up or same with Shaq I
would say in years past yes but if you
look at the numbers his free-throw
attempts are down during these playoffs
he's doing more he's facilitating more
and I think that's the reason why the
cavs are gotten off to attend until
starting these playoffs you know we
talked about last week he is
spoon-feeding these guys I mean Oh Kevin
Love man Kevin Love Shumpert jr. Smith
Channing Frye when LeBron gets into that
mid post area and we've been for years
saying that he needed to post up game
there's three or four jerseys around him
and those guys are just chillin in the
corner knocking down threes and I think
coach Lewis did a good job of finally
defining roles and getting Kevin Love
involved because you were gonna need
that third guy Kyrie LeBron has played
fantastic but love even though a
shooting hasn't been great his play at
both ends especially on the boards and
defining his role saying we're gonna get
you X amount of shots and we're gonna
put you in in these type of
pick-and-roll plays and I think that's
why the Cavs of taking that next step
do you really believe that tyronn lue in
the huddle told LeBron to shut the bleep
up
that was the report
that at one point during the season he
told him I do believe it look coach Lu
has been around a lot of strong
personalities in Kobe he's been around
Doc Rivers obviously Phil Jackson
winning a championship there Shaq so I
think he understands that there at times
you're going to need tough talk and the
way you're gonna get respect and the
best coach I ever played for who was
like that was coach Brown he didn't give
a who you were he treated the best
player in the 12th player the same so if
you weren't doing your job he would
berate you in front of everyone not
malicious but to get you going and if
the twelfth man sees that he's gonna
bust his heart his behind just as hard
as the first guy and I think coach Liu
recognized the writing on the wall
between Blatt and LeBron earlier that
LeBron was basically you know running
the asylum there and I think he's he's
grabbed the Rays he respects LeBron
don't get me wrong I don't want to say
it's you know it's like Gregg Popovich
because Gregg Popovich does the same
thing in San Antonio and that's why he
has five championships but the coach has
the coaching lead and players have to
play hard for that coach and I think
he's got in that respect we'll continue
with Reggie Miller I got a couple of
questions for him including if he could
play for any of these teams still
playing in the NBA the Final Four
yes who would you want to play for and
is Jeff hornacek actually a good hire
for the Knicks because maybe he doesn't
have to bring in the triangle offense
anymore so we'll continue with Reggie
Miller and we'll do so next on the day
of the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings
on audience